Traduttore: Luisa Lualdi
Revisore: Andrea Busetto
Cos’è il tempo?
Beh, tutti noi sappiamo cos’è il tempo,
viviamo nel tempo,
è un concetto primitivo
che noi tutti conosciamo.
Eppure è molto difficile descrivere, dare
una definizione esatta del tempo.
Questo lo sapeva anche Sant’Agostino,
che scriveva appunto:
“Che cos’è dunque il tempo? Se nessuno
me ne chiede lo so bene: ma se volessi
darne spiegazione a chi me ne chiede,
non lo so.”
Potremmo definire il tempo come quello
che ci permette di vedere lo scorrere
degli eventi dal passato al futuro,
attraverso il presente.
Ecco, c’è quindi una specie di freccia
del tempo, potremmo dire,
una simmetria nello scorrere del tempo,
in quanto nelle tre dimensioni spaziali
possiamo tranquillamente andare
avanti e indietro, a destra e sinistra
in alto e in basso, mentre il tempo…
dobbiamo per forza andare in avanti.
D’altronde tutti noi nasciamo, cresciamo,
invecchiamo e moriamo,
sempre in questa direzione.
E lo sperimentiamo nella vita di tutti
i giorni, ad esempio se vediamo un filmato
come questo, come per magia c’è una
persona che prende dei pezzi di banana
e con un coltello “zac, zac, oplà!”,
magicamente ricostruisce una banana
com’era di partenza.
Oppure vediamo quest’altro filmato,
dove ci sono delle persone esultanti,
che applaudono perché vedono questa
nuvola di fumo e polvere dalla quale,
come per magia, nascono due grattacieli.
Ecco, questi due filmati sono strani,
sono bizzarri.
Capiamo subito che c’è un trucco,
il trucco è presto detto:
stiamo vedendo il filmato al contrario,
indietro nel tempo, in quanto
i fenomeni macroscopici della nostra vita
quotidiana avvengono solo in una direzione
sono irreversibili, nel senso che
vederli in senso opposto
è strano, bizzarro, non succede mai.
Ecco che… quindi questo è essenzialmente
il cuore del concetto
del secondo principio della termodinamica,
che dice che
“l’entropia dell’universo aumenta sempre.”
Ora, è difficile spiegare
cos’è il concetto di entropia;
senza essere perfettamente rigorosi,
l’entropia potremmo associarla
al concetto di disordine.
Se prendiamo ad esempio questa matrice
di tessere, blu e gialle, e le mischiamo
in maniera caotica, le mischiamo,
le mischiamo…
a un certo punto raggiungeremo una
configurazione tipo questa che c’è
a destra,
dove le tessere sono alla rinfusa.
Se ora continuiamo a mischiarle e a
mischiarle, prima o poi ci chiediamo:
“ Ritorneremo alla situazione di partenza
dove tutte le tessere blu
sono a sinistra e le tessere
gialle a destra?”
La risposta è no. Il tempo fluisce
solo in questa direzione,
verso lo sparpagliamento,
verso il disordine, o meglio,
non è impossibile tornare alla
condizione di partenza;
è possibile ma è semplicemente
altamente improbabile.
Ecco, questo è il concetto dell’entropia;
l’aumento dell’entropia ci spiega
l’aumento del disordine, quindi ci spiega
questa unidirezionalità
della freccia del tempo.
Mi ricordo quando, forse ero alle
superiori, mi spiegarono
per la prima volta cos’era l’entropia,
provai a utilizzarlo come scusa
per mia mamma che si lamentava che la mia
camera era disordinata, io dicevo:
“Eh, non è colpa mia, è l’entropia
che aumenta dell’universo”.
Però è una scusa che non funzionava,
ovviamente.
Ecco che allora, se l’entropia dell’
universo è destinata sempre a crescere,
allora capiamo che alla fine la morte
dell’universo sarà per entropia,
cioè sarà quella che si chiama
la morte termica dell’universo,
dove cioè tutta la materia e l’energia
saranno sparpagliati in maniera omogenea,
per cui non ci sarà più possibile
fare nessuna trasformazione,
e quindi non sarà più possibile
neanche la vita.
Ecco ma… che cos’è allora la vita?
Shrödinger, premio Nobel per la Fisica,
uno dei padri della meccanica quantistica,
nel suo libro del 1944,
What is life, Cos’è la vita,
disse appunto che la vita si nutre di
entropia negativa, cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che un essere vivente non solo
combatte gli effetti nefasti
dell’aumento di entropia, che lo
porterebbe alla morte prematura,
ma addirittura fa il contrario, lavora
contro l’entropia per creare ordine,
per creare strutture, informazioni.
Infatti se ci tagliamo il nostro corpo è
in grado di ripristinare la ferita
e ripristinare i tessuti.
Vent’anni dopo, nel ’64, la NASA
chiese a un gruppo di ricercatori
di cercare la vita su Marte o su altri
pianeti, e allora uno di questi
James Lovelock, si chiese:
“Cosa possiamo fare per riconoscere
la vita su un altro pianeta?”
Una vita magari diversa dalla nostra,
non basata sul carbonio;
non ci aspettiamo di vedere persone con
due braccia e due gambe come noi,
allora qual è la risposta che diede?
Beh, per cercare la vita dobbiamo
cercare delle isole di bassa entropia.
Questa forse è la definizione
più generale di vita:
la vita è organizzazione, è informazione,
è strutture complesse, cioè bassa entropia
Questo tuttavia non contraddice il
secondo principio della termodinamica,
perché si può anche creare un’isola
di bassa entropia, a patto che
la diminuzione di entropia
che si ha in un certo punto,
in un certo istante di tempo,
sia più che bilanciata
dall’aumento di entropia
del mondo attorno.
Ecco che allora, se torniamo all’esempio
che facevo prima
della mia cameretta quand’ero piccolo,
io potrei mettermi a piegare i vestiti
ordinarli, impilarli bene dentro l’armadio
ma facendo questo devo fare fatica,
ci metto del tempo,
alla fine magari sono sudato,
e quindi mi raffreddo scambiando
il mio calore con l’ambiente,
e quindi le molecole dell’aria si agitano
perché aumenta il calore,
e questa agitazione è entropia,
è aumento di disordine,
e questo aumento di disordine
si dimostra che è maggiore dell’ordine
che io ho messo nei vestiti piegati.
Quindi non si può fare niente, l’entropia
dell’universo per forza
deve sempre aumentare.
E quindi anche il concetto di riciclo
delle cose che noi usiamo
in tutti i giorni è sicuramente
fondamentale, ma non è la risposta ultima.
Infatti, riciclando comunque c’è bisogno
di prendere le sostanze, rimaneggiarle,
e quindi si spende lavoro, fatica, e alla
fine comunque il bilancio di entropia
è a nostro sfavore, cioè non possiamo
combattere contro l’aumento dell’entropia.
E quindi la vera risposta per rallentare
la morte del nostro pianeta
è quella di, prima ancora di riciclare,
è di consumare poco, appunto.
Però non abbiamo ancora detto
perché l’entropia aumenta.
Per spiegare perché l’entropia aumenta
possiamo tornare al nostro esempio
delle tessere blu tutte a sinistra
e gialle tutte a destra.
Ora vediamo un filmato, qui a sinistra,
dove ad ogni fotogramma si scambiano
di ordine due tessere, a caso, si prendono
due tessere a caso e le si scambia.
Vediamo che pian piano aumenta
il disordine;
ora facciamo andare il filmato molto più
veloce, 32 volte più veloce di prima,
e vediamo che rapidamente si mischia, e
vediamo che saliamo nella curva di destra
verso una situazione definitiva del 50%.
Qui a destra, questo grafico rappresenta
la percentuale di tessere gialle
che ci sono a sinistra.
A sinistra inizialmente tutto era blu,
per cui partiamo da zero,
e pian piano aumenta aumenta finché
giustamente alla fine
più o meno statisticamente, legge dei
grandi numeri, avremo metà tessere
a sinistra e metà a destra, 50%.
Questo scenario finale è quello che noi
potremmo chiamare, appunto,
la fine dell’universo, quella che
prima ho chiamato la morte termica
dell’universo,dove tutto si è sparpagliato
e da lì non ci si sposta più.
Però se guardiamo con attenzione,
facciamo una lente d’ingrandimento,
vediamo che in questa regione, in realtà,
50% è solo la media,
in realtà è un processo dinamico, l’ordine
cresce e decresce attorno al 50%.
Per cui se questo fosse l’andamento dell’
entropia non di queste piccole tessere,
ma dell’universo intero, e
ci trovassimo ad esempio qui,
nel punto di minimo, vedremmo che l’
entropia aumenterebbe sia andando a destra
cioè avanti nel tempo, nel futuro,
sia andando a sinistra,
cioè indietro nel tempo, nel passato.
E quindi diremmo che non c’è un senso
unico, il tempo può fluire
in entrambe le direzioni, non c’è
freccia del tempo.
Ancora di più, se vivessimo invece in
questo istante di tempo indicato
dalla freccia rossa, cioè sull’apice,
allora diremmo che non solo
non c’è freccia del tempo, perché
in entrambe le direzioni,
il passato e il futuro, l’entropia ha lo
stesso carattere, ma per di più diremmo
che il secondo principio della
termodinamica è sbagliato in quanto
il futuro, o il passato, comunque ci porta
a una diminuzione dell’entropia
non un aumento.
Quindi capiamo che noi non stiamo
vivendo in questo scenario, stiamo
piuttosto vivendo negli eventi iniziali,
in un universo ancora giovane,
ancora ordinato: l’uomo si trova qui.
Se noi guardiamo al futuro vediamo
un aumento di entropia,
se guardiamo al passato vediamo una
diminuzione di entropia, quindi c'è una
freccia del tempo, il tempo può scorrere
solo in una certa direzione,
e quindi la vera domanda ora è capire
il perché del punto partenza.
Perché all’inizio tutto era ordinato,
come le nostre tessere,
tutte blu da una parte,
tutte gialle dall’altra?
Beh, noi sappiamo che all’inizio
dell’universo c’era il Big Bang.
Il Big Bang, tutta la materia era tutta
concentrata in una piccola regione,
grande come la punta del mio pollice,
quindi a temperature
elevatissime e a pressioni elevatissime.
Ora, come faceva l’universo a far
stare tutta la materia,
l’energia, in uno spazio così piccolo?
Beh, possiamo pensare ad una valigia.
Se noi vogliamo mettere un sacco
di cose dentro la nostra valigia,
le mettiamo alla rinfusa,
non ci starà molto dentro la valigia,
giusto?
Se invece vogliamo farci stare molti
vestiti e oggetti, cosa dobbiamo fare?
Dovremo prendere un po’ di tempo,
con calma piegare bene i vestiti,
utilizzare ogni minimo spazio e
organizzare bene il tutto.
Ecco, per il Big bang è la stessa cosa:
per poter far stare tutto in uno spazio
così piccolo, l’universo doveva essere
a istanti primordiali molto ordinato
E a questo punto ci stiamo chiedendo,
qual è veramente l'ultima domanda
che i cosmologi ci stanno facendo
in questo momento?
I cosmologi stanno cercando di capire
l’origine dell’universo, perché l’universo
all’inizio era così ordinato. Vi dico
subito che la risposta non esiste,
non sappiamo ancora, sono più di 50 anni
che ci lavoriamo, qual è il vero motivo
per cui all’inizio tutto era così
ordinato, a bassa entropia.
Ci sono diversi scenari, e vi faccio un
elenco dei possibili scenari,
lascio a voi scegliere quale vi sembra,
secondo voi il più ragionevole.
Il primo scenario è una risposta che
in realtà non è una risposta,
il primo scenario dice: “ È così, e basta,
bisogna accettarlo senza farsi domande.”
Però capiamo bene che l’essere umano
intelligente si fa queste domande, vuole,
pretende una risposta, vuole capire il
perché, se c’è qualcosa di particolare,
non di casuale, ci dev’essere stato
qualcosa sotto.
E infatti qualcuno, secondo scenario,
pensa che questa
sia la prova scientifica più vera e più
profonda dell’esistenza di Dio,
o chiamatelo come volete, di un Ente
superiore che ha voluto e potuto
creare l’universo così ordinato all’inizio
e adesso noi siamo 14 miliardi di anni
dopo a osservare quello che succede.
Oppure ci sono altre teorie,
una teoria mi piace chiamarla
il teorema della scimmia instancabile, non
so se conoscete la scimmia instancabile,
è una scimmia che voi mettete davanti a
una macchina da scrivere, a una tastiera
e questa schiaccerà a caso i tasti
senza saper scrivere.
Se è instancabile, quindi avete un tempo
infinito davanti a voi,
e direi anche un numero infinito
di fogli a disposizione,
ecco che prima o poi, per caso, riuscirà
addirittura a scrivere la Divina Commedia.
Ecco, applicato al Big Bang potremmo dire
che l’universo è così grande
ed ha così tanto tempo, non ha fretta
l’universo, che prima o poi
semplicemente mischiando a caso quelle
fluttuazioni di tessere che abbiamo visto
si disporranno per caso in maniera
completamente ordinata, che è il Big Bang.
E da lì noi siamo evoluti in quello
che vediamo oggi;
solo che questa fluttuazione che porta
per caso ad un ordine così elevato
è effettivamente improbabile,
ma veramente improbabile
tanto che questa teoria oggi è in pratica
non accreditata da nessuno scienziato.
È piuttosto più probabile un altro
scenario, quindi il quarto
quello che si chiama il cervello di
Boltzmann, che è un po’ un paradosso,
e dice, piuttosto che creare il Big bang
che necessita di un ordine incredibile,
di una fluttuazione molto elevata, è più
probabile piuttosto che in questo momento
nell’universo esista solo una
mente senziente, una mente che potrebbe
essere la vostra in questo momento,
e tutto il resto cos’è?
Niente, una finzione, generata dal
nostro subconscio.
Esiste solo una mente autocosciente,
questo l’abbiamo già visto in molti film,
ad esempio in Matrix, dove si dice che
quello che noi vediamo, la realtà
in effetti non è vera ma è una finzione
del nostro subconscio,
una proiezione del nostro cervello.
Ecco poi esistono altri scenari,
ad esempio quello del multiverso.
Il multiverso è una parolaccia che vuol
dire che non c’è un universo;
in contrapposizione all’universo ci sono
tanti universi, universi paralleli, quindi
il Big Bang non è davvero l’inizio
di nulla, ma è un punto all’interno
di un universo madre più grande, magari
dove si è raggiunto l’equilibrio termico,
dove non c’è una freccia del tempo,
e semplicemente all’interno di questi
universi paralleli si crea quello che noi
conosciamo, che è il Big Bang.
Ci sono diversissimi, tantissimi altri
scenari che si potrebbero verificare,
e potrebbero essere la vera risposta,
basti pensare che recentemente
sappiamo che l’universo che noi conosciamo
in realtà è solo il 5% del tutto,
cioè il 90% della materia e dell’energia
dell’universo in realtà è fatto
di materia oscura e di energia oscura, e
ancora non conosciamo bene come funzionino
Ecco potrebbe essere che in futuro,
studiando meglio l’energia oscura
e la materia oscura sia possibile dare una
definitiva spiegazione del perché
l’universo è partito dal Big Bang così
ordinato, e quindi spiegare cos’è
effettivamente l’entropia,
perché l’entropia aumenti sempre
quindi spiegare cos’è il tempo,
cos’è la freccia del tempo,
e in definitiva, che cos’è la vita.
Grazie.